hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and
i'm just checking in on you just
checking in on you
seeing how your day's going
seeing how life's going for you and all
of that type of [ __ ]
um
i got to be honest with you old freckles
old freckles finally moving the [ __ ]
workout in the right direction after i
tried that stupid intermittent fasting
that just completely shuts down your
metabolism
so [ __ ] stupid do you want to lose
weight uh don't eat anything for 17
hours oh great then my body feasts on
what little muscle i have then i'm
walking around like [ __ ] spongebob
squarepants but my stomach's flat
what am i some kind of [ __ ] who
listens to someone
you know what's really annoying i don't
understand as a [ __ ] out-of-shape
personal trainer if i see one more
[ __ ] out-of-shape personal trainer
it's [ __ ] working out i'm looking at
this guy he's like telling this person
what to do it's like dude you're not
even in shape
[Laughter]
i'm gonna get you in shape
by getting you to not do what i'm doing
because if you do what i'm doing i mean
i mean you as a personal trainer you
shouldn't look like your clients
right unless they're they're towards the
end of the journey
all right give me 10 of these give me 10
of these are you ordering food are we
still talking about working out you
[ __ ]
man titted tub of [ __ ]
oh i'm going in
i'm going i'm i'm [ __ ] uh
i'm gonna be controversial on this one
um
i'm gonna solve the gun problem
in the united states of america right
now
uh why don't you why don't you just do
it like a pilot's license
you know what i mean like when you get a
gun like when you get like a pilot's
license
you know
you're flying cessna's or whatever you
can't just go [ __ ] flying american
airlines jet
you got to work your way up you got to
get raided
you know i don't think if you get like a
[ __ ] gun license i think the first
thing you should get regardless of your
[ __ ] age is you get a little sick
shooter
it's all they give you
or maybe one of those little saturday
night specials
get a little one-shot thing
that's all the [ __ ] you get
right
and then
as you work your way up to more and more
powerful guns that could potentially do
way more [ __ ] damage you have to pass
major major psychological evaluation
and if you do the world is your oyster
and you can have whatever [ __ ]
weapon you want how about that does that
work out for everybody i wasn't saying
take guns away i wasn't saying this i
wasn't saying that i wasn't talking
about [ __ ]
gender gender neutral glocks
just saying you know [ __ ] lunatics
[ __ ] lunatics at some point can can
you not make it
easy for a [ __ ]
lunatic
to do oh my god i don't want to talk
about because it's just it's so [ __ ]
overwhelming i can't [ __ ] imagine
all of those people what the what they
what they're going through it's just and
it's just
i don't know
i don't know there's people still i
don't know
just and i think the left is [ __ ]
stupid because then they start yelling
at people
on you know
on the right not saying
everybody on the right has a gun not
saying everybody in the left doesn't
like guns i'm just saying like that this
[ __ ] thing where you just start
yelling at the other side how about you
just go hey what if we do this
what if we you know uh you know try to
weed out the bad apples by uh doing this
as long as you're not hey hey hey as
long as you're not [ __ ] crazy
we'll give you a [ __ ] bazooka
right and you can take it outside of
your backyard and go [ __ ] shoot at
something i don't give a [ __ ]
um someone would have a problem with
that oh that's a way to control people
it's a [ __ ] um anyway
let's get back to bread and circus
um
let's get back to bread and circus here
how about this how about those [ __ ]
boston celtics they are one game away
they are one game away the exact amount
of games that i've watched during this
[ __ ] playoff series because i've been
so [ __ ] busy i watched a little bit
of tonight's game and uh i watched it
basically until about half time
and uh
i was loving watching steven a smith
trash and how bad the shooting was and
it's just like stephen why don't you get
out there and show them how it's done
[Laughter]
i always love sports analysts who never
played the game at any sort of a [ __ ]
level it's there's just something
hilarious about that i mean i'm not
[ __ ] on him specifically i'm just
saying a lot of them do it and i i was
kidding who i [ __ ] do it too but it's
just
maybe because my team was involved
and he's just sitting there it's like
well you know they also have like the
walking wounded are out there at this
time of year so there's got to be some
problems i'll tell you what's funny i
think everybody just thinks that golden
state's just going to [ __ ] walk in
there and take the whole goddamn thing
that's what they think
uh
you wait if we get by the heat cause you
never know the heat's been there a bunch
of times i'm not saying the series is
over but i'll tell you right now we have
a straggle all it's only three to two
it's not three to one three or two we'll
see how it goes
we went down three to the last [ __ ]
series and uh we came back and won it so
uh we really really what the [ __ ] do i
know nothing
i know jack
[ __ ]
squad that's what i know
um
my kids are now at the age where i bribe
them
that's the deal
you know
on little [ __ ] on big [ __ ] i just say
hey listen
all right i'm taller than you
i'm paying for everything so the way i
say it goes on on on like major things
but on minor things
i'm a big [ __ ] softy and i've never
thought i'd be the parent that does that
you know
i start telling like listen you can take
the car down the driveway by yourself
if you put your toys away you know i go
with big bribes
no it's literally cookies i'll tell you
right now as a parent you really
appreciate girl scout cookies the mint
ones
you know
that is basically
that's like three months of housework
you can get your kids to do
picking up their own [ __ ] toys
pick up your toys they'll give you a
cookie cookie
they get all excited cookie yeah come on
let's go
what is that [ __ ] song
this is a song on one of the one of
those kid shows that they watch
about putting [ __ ]
away was it clean up clean up bad people
put your stuff away put your [ __ ] away
when that's not [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is it
everybody clean up clean up
put your stuff or why how to camp about
ghosts
but it's always put your stuff away
and it's like really hard not to say
[ __ ] i do know that
speaking of [ __ ] that's how the red sox
were playing
for the first six weeks now they're on
fire
they're on fire do they win again
tonight they're up one enough the last i
saw what about trevor story
who's become the story
in major league baseball the major
league baseball player of the week
not just the american league as far as i
know
he's the player of the goddamn week i
was watching him the other day
the guy [ __ ] goes out there he uh
what do you open the first inning he had
a three-run [ __ ] homer this guy had
no home runs about two weeks ago he now
has like nine
i'm telling you
we're going to catch up with the i don't
even catch up with the yankees the
yankees look great although they're
starting up they're starting to play
like [ __ ]
it is what it is it is what it is let's
see if the red sox one tonight
let's see if the red sox won tonight oh
by the way so i started losing weight
again oh
you [ __ ] we scored one run on the top of
the first
when did they get us the fifth inning
when our status arm got tired dude why
didn't he [ __ ] pull him dude i was
saying pull the guy in the [ __ ] third
inning did they listen no they did not
dude i could be a manager
dude the second he [ __ ] walks
somebody i'm gonna be like hey buddy go
hit the [ __ ] showers
all right hey and and guess what thanks
for [ __ ] nothing
thanks for nothing you sucked kid
you're going back down to pawtucket all
right
i hope you like illiteracy cause you're
going back to rhode island
you know when i was younger there was
they were voted one of the most
illiterate states
one of the most i think the most
illiterate state i don't know where it
was it was like rhode island and then
like mississippi but mississippi had you
know
they had an excuse anybody down south
has an excuse you lost the war and we
never [ __ ] treated you right we never
treated you like equals ever since big
major [ __ ] up by the north
you know what i mean
it's kind of like when a president gets
elected
and once the president gets elected then
everybody who's in that party acts like
a [ __ ] for four [ __ ] years
you know what i mean
like i don't know when uh
when george w was in office
like 99 of the republican people out
there were just acting like [ __ ]
and then obama got in and then all the
lefty people were acting like [ __ ] and
then trump gets in and out jesus
it was like it was like uh coachella for
[ __ ] when he was [ __ ] running and
then everybody got so excited that they
got the guy out and now we're left with
this guy forgetful freddy
is gonna go over and talk to china
i don't know what i'm talking about
right now i know he's doing something
that taiwan they're [ __ ] trying to go
to taiwan we're gonna try to be like hey
could you guys like
not do what we're doing
[Laughter]
could you not invade an innocent country
could you not [ __ ] do that for your
own
betterment your own needs
um
i'll get some [ __ ] tweets on that one
why don't you [ __ ] move to finland
you [ __ ] commied freckle [ __ ] um
cause i calls them as i seize them
anyway
the [ __ ] was i looking up here the other
day
i literally just saw it i was sitting
there trying to plug this [ __ ] thing
in
oh a cappuccino versus uh
machiatto one of these ones has like
[ __ ] hot chocolate in it and i had it
i had a coffee with hot chocolate in it
whatever that was because with an m
and uh it was [ __ ] disgusting
it just didn't it didn't taste like good
coffee and it didn't taste like good hot
chocolate and i was thinking like you
know what i need to try one of these
again
if i'm ever in europe
if i'm like in italy
or in france
which i don't know when the [ __ ] that's
gonna happen but if i ever if i ever am
again
um i'm gonna try it out there and i bet
they do it right
you know
i can't like write off that whole thing
but i had really high hopes for it
and uh it just tasted like way too
[ __ ] sugary i wasn't into it and i
realized like this is this is where i
settled
with uh coffee you just wanted an
espresso that you say espresso
that's the one you want you just want a
shot of it
you do it it's [ __ ] delicious there's
no cream there's no sugar it's the same
way i used to drink booze
you know
you start off you don't know what you're
doing you add all of this [ __ ] to the
booze
and by the end of it you're like i just
want the booze you want an ice cube no i
don't i just the booze
give me
give me the booze remember that
from way back when on the [ __ ] uh
the [ __ ] was that show intervention
remember that show that was a guilty
pleasure
watching families fall apart as your
entertainment to put you to sleep
there's really a heartless thing to
[ __ ] late night tv
there really is it's about people
swindling people out of money people
killing people people with like
addictions
it's like uh
i don't know just like the [ __ ] dregs
of society
and you just sit down and you watch it
people with wooden teeth on meth
digging a well by hand and like what are
they doing and how come i haven't seen
your mailman in a while next thing you
know they find the guy
they find his postal bag like floating
in the [ __ ] jacuzzi and they're like
well i don't know how that got in there
how do you know the wind didn't blow it
off there and then they start digging
around their yard
and they find that big ring of keys and
then they he's here he's gonna be here
they bring a [ __ ] bloodhound in or
some [ __ ] like that one of those drug
sniffing dogs
and then they find the guy
and then you fall asleep you fall asleep
to it
fall asleep to a whole family reading
[ __ ] letters
you know just some guy who can't stop
sniffing glue
like how did you first get into sniffing
glue well you know i always went down to
hobbytown
you know i used to like making the
models and after a while you know
i liked
buying the stuff to make a model more
than the model itself
and my parents were going like you know
you're buying more glue again
you're more pain where's the malt what
are you working on oh you know it's a
secret
what am i working on
what am i working on living at home till
i'm 40
[Music]
[Laughter]
my wife [ __ ] watches all of those
damn shows it's just like that snl
sketch where they say the women they
fall asleep watching murder shows my my
wife [ __ ] watches all of that [ __ ]
and i've just literally i i had to give
in to it
it was a quiet town
things like this didn't happen around
here
i'd say the scariest ones are when the
[ __ ] women are out killing people
that's the one it's just like you're not
supposed to do that [ __ ] it's always
amazing when you see like
women are just trying to be so equal to
men that they even want to do the dumb
[ __ ] that we do
like commit murder
it's like you know out of all of you
could have left that one alone
you know
you're really taking this feminism thing
to a whole new leg you know i am very
proud to be the first
woman on death road
in [ __ ] connecticut or whatever you
know
death row has been for a long time an
all boys club
you're so brave
that'd be a weird thing to do just to be
the first
the first one of you to get on death row
what would your final meal be or you
know what mine would be i'd have a
[ __ ] pot roast
pot roast with no lumpy potatoes mashed
potatoes with gravy and some stewed
carrots
a little bit of ketchup on the side mix
that in with the gravy and then a nice
fresh loaf of bread
right
then fight evan and then i have an ice
cold glass of ice water
and then for dessert
i would have uh
i'm not a [ __ ] dessert guy anymore
but i also don't want to die so i have
to [ __ ]
have to order dessert to make it stretch
out the meal
you guys want appetizers yeah absolutely
what would you like for an appetizer
what takes the longest to make
i would like uh i would like a breaded
penguin wing
you know then buy another [ __ ]
month to your life
um
and in his last act of meanness he
actually ate a penguin
how could you do that they're so cute
um
that's the worst thing about being a
chicken you're ugly and delicious
there's just no reason for anybody to go
out and save you i will tell you this
though
um for all the [ __ ] people out there
that want to make carnivores like myself
vegetarians just keep making
documentaries
about different animals because every
time i see one about one i stop eating
that animal
you know i i haven't [ __ ] with lobster
in forever because i just don't like how
they kill once i saw how they killed
them like they didn't they just boiled
them alive
and they're like oh you know that
doesn't feel it
is is that what it is
or does it not communicate in a [ __ ]
way that you can understand are you
fluent in lobster do you have that
[ __ ] rosetta stone on your bookshelf
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
i think the thing would understand it
would be have some sort of nervous
system that would send a signal that
you're getting into water that's gonna
kill you i would think so i don't [ __ ]
with lobster
and uh i used to eat octopus now i can't
eat octopus because they made this
[ __ ] unbelievable documentary where
this guy befriended a [ __ ] octopus
and in the end when the thing has
reached the end of its life it's like
the beginning of bambi you're like
almost [ __ ] crying right and i was
like i'm never eating another [ __ ]
octopus i i really i i like those things
you know
and now i'm seeing all these [ __ ]
scuba divers taking fish hooks out of
shark's mouths
and they get them out of pain and then
they somehow meet the shark again and
the sharks all cool with them those ones
i don't get it's like the [ __ ]
thing's in the ocean
you know i mean you can get lost in a
mall and never see your [ __ ] friend
again back in the day before cell phones
and [ __ ] right you guys would just have
to go home in separate cars and
call each other three days later dude
what happened i couldn't find you
oh i thought you said the information
booth at three o'clock i was there at 2
30. right
like how the [ __ ] do you do that you
come back and the shark is still
just still there
i don't know
i'll tell you what a problem in a
disease human beings are when you really
think of the vastness of the ocean and
how deep it is and how unexplored it is
yet
everything in the ocean is dealing with
the fact that there's [ __ ] human
beings out there throwing out flat
screen tvs
um
i i feel like that should have been
illegal you should never have been able
to dump something into the ocean because
we don't live there if you want to [ __ ]
up the land like where we're from
like that they'd be like all right
you're [ __ ] up your own habitat that
makes sense but to take your [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh it's old billy cars button hit this
weekend ah jesus this episode what's he
doing here
um
i'll tell you what i've been doing with
playing [ __ ] drums a little bit
the end of the edit there i had a great
argument with my wife the other day i
wish she was here to talk about it
it was such a great argument
where like she got so mad at me
and i came upstairs you know
to discuss it she started [ __ ] laying
into me i said hey you know what let's
not yell
all right i got what's the matter and
she [ __ ] told me what i did i was
like all right i did that
and then she said the other thing i said
all right i did that too all right so
i'm sorry about that
uh i understand why it made you feel
that way and i i feel bad that i did
that i won't do that anymore because i
love you right
and then i was able to say what she did
that bugged me
and we [ __ ] just
got to the other side of it i'm like
alright are we good can we watch one of
your murder shows now
[Laughter]
mudslides could it happen to you tonight
at 12 a.m
[ __ ] mudslide who dies in a mudslide
jesus christ
a mudslide
let me look this up what are the odds
the odds
of
dying
let's see what came up while skydiving
in a car crash in a plane crash on mount
everest on your birthday
on a roller coaster
in a motorcycle oh that's great and i'm
almost like these all people buying
motorcycles
um or they don't want somebody do what
are the odds of dying
in
a mud
slide
how many deaths result from lands oh
landslides sorry
what do you guys think
an average of 25 to 50 people are killed
by landslides each year oh my god
literally the earth just swallows you up
23 people were killed and at least 167
injured and more than 400 homes were
damaged by a series of debris flows that
impacted the california community
ah she's gonna make me do the [ __ ]
math here
an average of 25 to 50 people
all right how many people live in
california
39 million
yeah there's almost 40 million [ __ ]
people out here
and each year 25 to 50 people somehow
don't see the earth sneaking up behind
them
um
knock knock who's there the earth what
um all right let's do a little read here
oh look who it is everybody it's helix
uh the best sleep i've ever had oh man
depends on there's different kinds of
sleep
there's comfort sleep
there's just being exhausted sleep
there's peaceful sleep there's passing
out
this getting knocked out
you're the best sleep i've ever had is
is afternoon naps as an adult
those are the best ones
just laying on a couch
waking up 20 minutes later cold isn't it
amazing how cold your body gets the
second you stop moving
like you can lay on a couch for [ __ ]
four hours watching tv and every once in
a while just fidgeting moving around
the second you fall asleep if you don't
have a blanket on you you wake up with
pneumonia all right helix sleep has a
quiz that takes just two minutes to
complete and matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be perfect the way
you sleep
sorry it was capitalized everybody's
unique
doesn't mean you're interesting
uh and helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium and
firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
mattress is great
for spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains and even a helix plus
mattress for plus size sleepers
so if you're looking for a mattress you
can take the quiz you order the mattress
that you match to and the mattress comes
right to your door
shipped
for free
right you don't ever need to go to a
mattress store again just go to
helixsleep.com
take their two minutes sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
they have a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it gross
if i ran that company didn't like it all
right throw it out but not in the ocean
bury it in the ground
uh but you will helix even has financing
options
and flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep is never far away helix is
offering up to two hundred dollars off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helix sleep.com
burr that's
helixsleep.com for up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows well guess who needs a new
[ __ ] mattress
this guy
i need a new mattress
i [ __ ] up my neck
i was climbing up a ladder to look at
something inside this closet
and i i
s you know look at the top shelf i was
trying to find my swimming goggles
because i was going to go jump in the
pool i'm a big goggles guy i don't like
going underwater with i want to be able
to see you know i like open my eyes and
get all that chlorine or whatever the
[ __ ] in our pool right
so i was looking for him and i set the i
set the ladder up right underneath the
door jam and i walked i wasn't even
going fast
and just the top of my [ __ ] charlie
brown head
just hit it flush
and there was nowhere for for it to go
like it wasn't a glancing blow it was it
was blunt just
just like that ah and i just felt it in
my neck i'm like all right that's gonna
[ __ ] with me
that's gonna [ __ ] so i've been
sitting in a chair while editing the
movie like with my hands on both sides
of my head like i'm trying to lift my
head up off my body
hoping that that's gonna work
and what i don't understand is if
someone else were to do that for me it
would really give me relief but for some
reason if i do the exact same thing i i
feel nothing
it's actually gotten a little bit better
a little bit better
um
my son's learning how to swim
uh my daughter almost has it down so
that's a big relief
big relief you know
uh
he can go like under the water and kind
of and then he comes up goes underwater
for like two seconds it comes back up
and he's all proud of himself
he's such a great kid
he really is i have two i have two of
the best kids ever like the ha everybody
says how happy my kids are i can't even
tell you how proud i am
of that
they're super happy they know that
they're loved they're funny as hell
adorable kids and uh
and every night around seven o'clock
they go absolutely bat [ __ ] crazy
running around the living room and i
don't even give a [ __ ]
you know
i'm getting rid of all of that [ __ ] from
when i grew up you know every every dad
on my block if you had any sort of
excitement hey hey call it
hey knock it off
you got to be all [ __ ] quiet and [ __ ]
it's like you're a kid
your body's brand new
you're trying it out you let him run
around the [ __ ] track
um
oh it's really really cool
so hopefully we can just keep along
doing this trend and i'm back studying
my french on pimsleur i'm getting all
caught up
i was up to i did the first 30 lessons
about a year ago and i was trying to get
my instrument rating and uh so i didn't
become fluent in french and i didn't
[ __ ] get my instrument rating because
i ended up selling a script but i made a
movie all right so i did do something
um but anyway oh here's some free
advertising you got to get those [ __ ]
david ortiz
firecracker cigars man they're great
like the size of a breakfast sausage i
love it every night i sit down on my
porch i [ __ ] unwind
you know
listen to some [ __ ] tunes and i i
smoke one of those things i think it's
just it's [ __ ] hilarious to me that
he's big poppy and then he has these
little ass cigars
you know
it's probably because he lives such a
cool life he doesn't have time to smoke
a full one you know he's a time to take
really quick and then
duck back in and continue being david
ortiz
um all right that's the podcast
everybody congratulations to the boston
celtics and everybody who's a celtic fan
that got to watch the games
i am uh doing my best to watch him um
and been peeking in here at the red sox
but uh
i don't know i got vegas this weekend
everybody i'm at the cosmopolitan
and i got a bunch of new [ __ ] and i
can't wait to do it
uh very excited about that and then that
ends my three weekends in a row run and
i've made up the dates that i cancelled
because of this
shooting this thing i think i got one
other one i got one in in uh
windsor canada that had to reschedule
and then one in like [ __ ]
pennsylvania or something like that that
was the other two but those are on the
books
so um
that is it
that is all
god bless you in the united states of
america and uh hey gun people what if
you get vegan instead of being yelled at
by a non-gun person i like guns i'm not
[ __ ]
[ __ ] on them i just didn't grow up
with them so i'm terrified of them but
like
what is your solution
what would work for you
where
you know
how would you solve
the right to bear arms
okay keeping that while
not having
these these
mass shootings
and these just these [ __ ] unspeakable
[ __ ] tragedies and the [ __ ] pain
that it causes
um i just can't even imagine
you know
it's it's really my problem with
believing in a higher power to be honest
with you that [ __ ] like this happens by
who's kidding who human beings that god
made
because i don't buy into that whole
[ __ ] devil scapegoat [ __ ] it's
like no dude you made this person and
this person was [ __ ] up
um
i don't know but anyway if does anybody
out there's got to be somebody out there
with a good solution you know there's a
lot of people that are on drugs that
have great solutions
for how addicts should be treated
so i'm not a gun guy so what the [ __ ] do
i know so i want to hear from gun people
right in i want to hear how what you
think
um
how do you solve what do you think about
my idea well you have to get raided like
on a pilot's license like you just
because you have a gun license doesn't
mean you can go and just buy any [ __ ]
gun like which each the the capability
of each gun
and the amount of damage that you could
do like these psychological tests
i mean everything else is like that
you know
you can't just be batshit crazy and go
fly a commercial [ __ ] airline you
can't [ __ ] do that
uh
you know you can be bad [ __ ] crazy and
be president um all right whatever
there's a lot of holes in my [ __ ]
ideas here but uh let's try to yes you
know try to see we'll see i would like
i'll be interested to hear your
solutions rather than people yelling at
each other and typing in capital letters
and all of that [ __ ] and uh you know
here's a test for you as an adult can
you present your opinion without
insulting the other side
can you do it
i know i can't you [ __ ] all right
that's
that's my podcast enjoy the music
uh picked out by the uh the amazingly
talented andrew themillis you guys ever
listen to him play guitar in some of his
music the [ __ ] guy and he's a
director
very very talented guy and then uh
afterwards we have a bonus episode of
the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcasts all right
have a great weekend you [ __ ] and i'll
see you on monday
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
may 26th
uh 2014 happy memorial day
happy memorial day
go to a parade show your [ __ ] respect
and go weed a bunch of burgers
um and then you'll get [ __ ] [ __ ] face
and say something that you shouldn't
have [ __ ] said maybe hit on your
wife's sister
get punched in your [ __ ] head um
anyways if you can hear the echo in the
room that i'm back downstairs as the the
project downstairs inches along
um you know those of you listen to this
podcast you know from a year and a half
ago not even a year and a half 14 months
ago when i had that [ __ ] water damage
um i like to think it was a blessing in
disguise
because the part of the house upstairs
was immaculate and i just redone that
room so that sucked but below it
was it was it was a [ __ ] tree fort it
was [ __ ]
it needed to be [ __ ] replaced anyways
it's a [ __ ]
i didn't want to get into it and now of
course they get under the house and what
i already knew was because i had
somebody do some electrical on my house
before
he was cleaning up a little bit down
there and he's in the crawl space which
is right underneath my living room and i
hear him down there every once in a
while i was hearing this guy just going
what the [ __ ]
so i knew it wasn't good
i knew it wasn't good and he told me
that there was a lot of [ __ ] work down
there and i'm lucky i didn't have a fire
and then he replaced most of it so
the foreman
on this other job
you know some of the stuff that they've
taken out they actually you know
accidentally disconnected the phone you
know [ __ ] happens as these guys work
on your house so
you know he reiterated
you know he didn't use the f-bomb but i
could tell by what he was talking about
that
i had some issues
in the electrical department
in my house so um
you know i'm gonna get that all taken
care of which brings me to my question
here
solar power everybody
can i take five minutes just to be a
[ __ ] hippie man
um
every once in a while i go in and out of
my [ __ ] you know i'm with the team
and now and then and then i'm against
the team you know
kind of like a [ __ ] uh
like a randy moss
you know
you come into town you got your mind
right and after about a season and a
half you start acting like a [ __ ]
maniac that's how i feel
when i look at uh
whatever the [ __ ] exp i'm really
trying to avoid the expression the
powers that be
but um
i don't know i can't help it every time
when i land
in los angeles and i look out at the
basin as they call it
um from the san gabriel mountains
all the way
south of that which is [ __ ] la in
greater la all of that just what an
absolute [ __ ] it is
and um
what happens
when the [ __ ] hits the fan so
i'm thinking about getting some solar
panels
and i know all you rednecks out there
are saying the obvious thing the [ __ ]
good the solar panel gonna do if you
ain't got a gun
what are you gonna keep the guy warm
that [ __ ] shoots you in the head and
steals your provisions i understand
their [ __ ]
bearded wonder all right i get it but i
one step at a time
one step at a [ __ ] time first thing i
want to do
i want to get
you know it's ridiculous
i live in a [ __ ] desert the house
bakes in the sun and i'm i still have
i don't have solar power it's the
dumbest [ __ ] ever
so uh i'm gonna look into it and what i
want to know is is
you know
is there two types of solar power
there's one where you're still on the
grid and then there's one where you're
off the grid i like off the grid
and if anybody's listening to my podcast
if you're off the grid like what happens
do they like it do they get mad at you
[Music]
i mean how do they know
because all of a sudden your bill goes
down does that like set off a light
you know and underneath the mountain
that all those illuminati guys live in
and then somebody pulls up to your house
hey i noticed you i haven't been making
any toast lately
and uh you know what's going on here
how come you're not you're not watching
t what are you reading books in there
[ __ ] eating apples off a tree
how come you're not using any electrical
uh tricity there
does that happen
is it it's not illegal to be off the
grid they just sort of [ __ ] uh
do they bully you at all like just let
me know what i'm in for
all right
because what i would love to do is to
continue
spending my legal tender that really has
nothing behind it other than the faith
of every freckled-faced [ __ ] over here
um i would really love to continue
existing
in this but i would like to have the
backup that if the [ __ ] does hit the fan
before i'm overrun by a mob
you know because mine's the only light
on the top of the hill see that's i used
to do a bit about that that's the thing
like if you actually have
if you're off the grid all right and
everything just goes [ __ ] haywire you
immediately you got to cut your lights
out quick
okay because the first thing when
everybody loses power they stand they go
oh you got to be [ __ ] [ __ ] me i
was watching two broke girls over here
right that's the first thing
you flip the switches is it and then
this you know within 30 seconds you're
like is it just our house and you look
out the window so you basically you have
30 [ __ ] seconds
to cut all your lights off
tell your wife to shut the [ __ ] up
and get downstairs
in that little corner room
all right
you put your hand on her shoulder
firmly
you don't hurt her but you're not
affectionate
you place your hand on her shoulder so
she knows that some pertinent [ __ ]
information is on the way
you say
honey the only ones left
we're the only ones left look at me stop
crying
we're the only one
with the only ones left
with power
and i need you
to hold it together
cry it out now
i want you to cry
every ounce of [ __ ] you have in you out
of you
in this corner of this house
okay
when you come upstairs
i want you to sit here and act like we
do not have power
okay so when the sullivans come across
the [ __ ] street
and see if we don't have power you lie
to their [ __ ] faces
shh
honey
forget about this elephants
they're not gonna make it
you understand
you know
i don't want that to happen i don't want
that to happen to anybody but i don't
want to be the sullivans
you know what i mean
i want a shot just give me a [ __ ]
shot
that's all i need i just need some solar
panels and a [ __ ] helicopter and i
will get the [ __ ] out of here
that's what you need you [ __ ] idiots
with your guns
huh what are you schwarzenegger how
long's that gonna last
um
anyway so i'm thinking about it does
anybody is anybody live in the la area
does anybody have solar panels anywhere
in the [ __ ] world can you recommend
are there two different kinds because i
actually looked up solar panels off the
grid
and uh i came to
this place uh blue pacific solar it says
off-grid packages
um
then there's another one that just says
get solar power sun power
off-grid systems upgrade system
backwoods solar electric systems
yeah i can install that [ __ ]
well what we're gonna do is we're gonna
bring it in and we'll just run it over
the outhouse
what
cabana what's that a
cigar um
[Music]
sorry
i'm in a stupid [ __ ] mood this week
um
yeah oh then there's one for australia
i don't mind paying the grid
but i would like to have if the grid
fails to have the then off the grid
switch how about that can we just have
that
those of you who've been on the internet
this week you know the direction that
i'm working in oh yes you do
to stop being modest you know the
direction i'm going in i'm talking about
solar [ __ ] roads
has anybody seen this this youtube video
it's [ __ ] amazing if if what they're
saying is true about these solar roads
um and i apologize for the narrator i
get what he's doing he's trying to
keep it interesting but he kept it
interesting too long and then he brings
it down to an interlude which should
have come a minute earlier and then he
goes back to screaming so it's a little
bit annoying
but uh just try to listen to the
information and then try not to get
sucked into a george bush obama debate
because uh
i don't know i don't know if these
things what the [ __ ] do i know right but
it's just they're basically saying if we
replaced
all our roads with these solar
[ __ ] things that literally makes it
look like lego land and it's all lit up
and there'd be sensors to let you know a
deer is going around the corner and then
it would just light up in the turn hey
there's a [ __ ] deer around the corner
you know enjoy your barley pancakes or
whatever right for some [ __ ] full-on
hippie [ __ ] and that basically
the amount of energy that it would
create
would be three times what this country
even needed
which immediately we can just leave the
middle east
right
we don't have to be over there pissing
them off by getting in the middle of
their [ __ ]
all right
we don't have to deal with oil
and oil money is what funds the
terrorists as far as my limited reading
goes right
the the families over there that [ __ ]
hang on she's scratching
i just gave you a bath what's wrong
oh cleo
um
anyways uh
yeah like the [ __ ] the oil people
over the people who make all the money
over there they then donate to mosques
and then in the mosque they [ __ ] you
know
kind of [ __ ] hey
you know
send it over to these [ __ ] people
over here that end up coming back at us
shooting [ __ ] at us as far as you know
like i said i don't know [ __ ]
cleo would you stop [ __ ]
you're gonna have to go to the other
room here come here buddy
what's up sweetheart
we went on a nice hike today didn't we
huh yes we're good
all right get out of here
um so anyways um
yeah and then that whole [ __ ] thing
is just null and void
we have all this extra power actually do
we create a bunch of jobs
the only thing i don't know is the way
it looks it doesn't seem like it's a
smooth ride it just seems like the whole
time you'll be going
like over these [ __ ] things i i have
no idea but
just check it out and i swear to god
because this is something that i don't
know if it is if it does work if it does
[ __ ] work
it could benefit everybody
conservatives liberals
independents everyone who wouldn't
benefit from all of this energy
oh that's right
the people in power
oh how could i forget that that's right
how do you think that they're going to
derail this if this actually becomes a
movement
how will they somehow
tie in terrorism 911 liberals [ __ ]
right-wing conservatives and just get
this the pot [ __ ] stirring so
everybody's screaming and yelling
it's gonna be prohibitively expensive
and the babies will starve
they're gonna do all of that [ __ ] um the
only way this thing gets off the ground
if it works
if it works
is if people don't get sucked into those
arguments
and we all become one
and we all pick up a hatchet
and we start marching towards the
bankers gated communities
okay
because the asphalt streets will have to
run red with blue blood money
before something wonderful like this
will ever [ __ ] happen because you are
[ __ ] with
a century and a half
of cash flow
going to a small amount of people that's
what you're [ __ ] with
and when you're [ __ ] with something
like that
that level of money
basically the money that gives the
dollar power like the only thing gives
the us dollar power is that oil barrels
of oil are still measured in us dollars
other than that it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] show
so these guys are the guys behind all of
that it's them and the [ __ ] bankers
and that's it all right the insurance
companies like the ted kennedy of that
[ __ ] family all right but [ __ ]
bobby and jack
all right
actually the banks are [ __ ] joe
kennedy
all right phil shut up with the kennedy
[ __ ] all right so anyways
that's my thing like this is a great
[ __ ] idea if it works if it works
it's a [ __ ] great idea
even if you just did a few roads if you
just did a few of them
each state just did like their main
highway or whatever
if you just did that
i can't imagine the amount of of money
it would save and on the less
oh man
it was incred the possibilities of it
are incredible i don't know if it works
but it is [ __ ] incredible but the sad
thing
is um
the fact that whenever new stuff like
this comes up it all just turns into
uh obama
bush republican democrat blah blah
everybody's just yelling at each other
and then it just [ __ ] goes away and
then everybody turns on sports
and that's what happens
so there you go there's all off the grid
billy 15 minutes of crazy talk but that
makes sense to me
makes sense to me man [ __ ] you know
we get this done if everybody wasn't so
so so [ __ ] liberal
all them liberals out there in hollywood
right i gotta tell you i'm i'm not just
making fun of
a stereotypical southern guy all right
because i having lived out here in
hollywood these people are out of their
[ __ ] minds they they're fox news to
the left they're out of their [ __ ]
minds
they're they're they're such [ __ ]
hypocrites where it's just like
you can say
the most uh i guess racist isn't the
word because you can make fun of white
people
rich white people you can basically you
can be uh
you can use the exact [ __ ] thing that
they don't like seeing used on poor
people against rich people and they
[ __ ] love it
you know
you can suggest that people from the
south are all [ __ ] their sisters and
they're slapping their knees and they're
doing the wave
in the crowd all right but if you
suggest any homeless guy needs to get
off his [ __ ] ass
stop boozing and get a [ __ ] job then
you're the devil so i mean i don't know
does that make any sense well it
shouldn't
isn't that why you listen to this
podcast you [ __ ]
all righty then let's uh let's do a
little bit of advertisements
i'd like to average any any solar people
want to advertise in this [ __ ]
podcast
how much does it cost all right e voice
everybody
e-voice e-voice
why don't you get this [ __ ] um e-voice
everyone you're a business owner but
automated phone systems and secretaries
are secretaries are not in your budget
just yet and juggling incoming calls can
make you seem like you're not even
professional well here's something that
will dramatically affect your ability to
make more money in 2014 what is it it's
e-voice everybody whether you're a
business of one or 100 e-voice will help
you manage all of your incoming calls
with a toll-free number dial by name
directory and call routing tools your
business will sound like a million bucks
can't take a call no problem evoice will
transcribe that voicemail and email it
right to you so you'll never be caught
off guard again and with e-voice you can
try it before you buy it over there
right now just for my listeners they're
only advertising here everybody this is
exclusive
you can get a 60-day
what the hell's with these typos this
week a 60-day trial of e-voice
absolutely free go to evoice.com and
enter the promo code bill bill for the
people who went to public schools do
that at checkout take charge of your
business and make more money in 2014 go
to evoice.com and enter in bill at
checkout for your 60-day free trial
that's e-voice promo code bill
okay oh here they are our old friends
dollar shave club
dollar shave club everybody there are so
many things that piss me off not having
solar robes
the fact that i rented a chevy impala
this week
because my truck's getting fixed
and it's supposed to be the flagship one
with the v8 that when i'm on the
slightest little bit of a hill and i go
to put it in reverse it rolls forward a
little bit like some hunk of crap from
the 70s
come on chevy you can do better than
that those are a few things that piss me
off and you know what else pisses me off
oh he's coming around again everybody
paying way too much to shave my freckled
face
is definitely up there
ah nothing feels better than shaving
with the fresh new blade everybody but
new razors are so ridiculously expensive
that you can't afford to change your
blade more than once every six months so
you end up scalping your face with an
old blade come on we've all been there
dollar shave you change your blade as
much as your chain you got to buy new
deodorant that's basically the deal
unless you're with uh donald trump
you know and then you pretend you have
money for blades you drive around your
dumb helicopter with your name on the
back
dollar shave club delivers top quality
raises for a few bucks a month dollar
shave club members always shave with a
fresh blade because they get a fresh
pack in the mail every month talk
candidly about your experiences with the
program well you just explained it
all right don't tell me what to do
dollar shave club i'll talk candidly
when i feel like it they've got lots of
other great products like the classic dr
cavey's ev shave butter
he's a shaved butter and dr cavey's post
shave
post shave that sounds very sexual
post dr carvey's poised codal coidle
sorry join the hundreds of thousands of
guys who've upgraded to the smarter way
to shave shave time shave money join
dollarshaveclub.com burr support this
podcast and a great company by going to
dollarshaveclub.com
dollarshaveclub.com that is a great
company
you know for years i used to sit there
going why the [ __ ] does it cost so much
goddamn money you know but all i did was
talk about it that son of a [ __ ] went
out and did it now he's the millionaire
oh geez all right let's talk sports here
all right let's start with the nba
something i never watch but you know
it's the conference finals
i've had some downtime so basically what
i've been doing is um it's the
the hockey conference finals and the the
nba conference finals so what i do is i
take the nba game as i watch the nhl
game live and then the following morning
i watched the nba game and i got to tell
you it's been a slice of heaven
it's been a slice of heaven
um and you know what i got back into nba
hoop and i got back into the simplicity
and the beauty of just coming out there
with the ball trying to put it through a
hoop it's a [ __ ] pure game it is a
wonderful game if those [ __ ] refs
would just got with that they would just
relax
classic example i don't even know who
won this game yet i'm gonna go watch it
as i upload i've only watched the first
quarter of the last okc
uh san antonio spurs game
all right
now as far as i understand the job of
the referee is to keep the game under
control
keep the game under control and let the
players decide who's going to win the
[ __ ] game
all right i watched the first quarter of
the game all right
okc is already in trouble because that's
serge ibaka guys that i say his name
their big man is hurt
all right so he's on the elliptical so
they got kendrick perkins in there and
what does the [ __ ] ref do gives him
three [ __ ] bulls two definite
[ __ ] [ __ ] calls and puts the guy
in the bench they already got one guy in
the elliptical you know they need
kendrick perkins and you give him two
bulls the guy had [ __ ] three fouls in
the first quarter the last two i swear
to god he was standing there scratching
his ass and they gave him a foul
then i watched him with uh who's who's
the guy there who who you know
uh what the [ __ ] his name that point
guard
who sometimes turns into an
eight-year-old ah begins with a w
why do i keep thinking witherspoon
because i'm old
you know what i'm talking about
that [ __ ] guy right
manu ginobili whatever his name is that
guy refuses to shave his [ __ ] head
steals the ball from him
all right
so you see the [ __ ] guy he turns into
the eight-year-old he runs right up and
tries to slap it away from takes a foul
and he's you know when he's sitting
there he doesn't even look at the ref he
says something like that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] and the ref is standing there
staring at him how do i know he's
staring at him because even the guy
announcing the game reggie miller i
think it was was going that ref should
have [ __ ] given him the foul and
walked away he stands there not only
stands there stands there staring at him
waiting for him to say something now i
know i know this guy probably has a
[ __ ] reputation for doing that but
it's just like that it's a complete
[ __ ] abuse of power and
these guys their job is to to keep the
game under control not control the pace
of the game and that's what i [ __ ]
hate about the nba all right there
okay there
sorry
i got my [ __ ] tampon
mentality this week but it's a [ __ ]
thing that i cannot stand about the nba
the goddamn officiating whether it's
fixed or not i don't [ __ ] know but
those guys
they need to relax cleo what is the
problem
what is the problem
i just gave you a bath i rinsed your
good
[ __ ] thing
i felt you know it's such a ridiculous
level how much i love that dog you know
what nothing thing drives me nuts
drives me nuts
um
anyways but it's still great what a
great series uh
even though okc is down
at this point two games tonight i don't
know if it's three at this point it's
just i don't know spurs are fun to watch
okc is fun to watch and uh
you know as much i imagine pacer fans
are frustrated with their team
you know they just don't know how to win
yet
they you know what they like they like
the little brother that's big enough at
this point
to finally win a fight against his older
brother but the the older brother has
the psychological advantage because he's
been kicking their ass
their entire [ __ ] life
you know oh hang on she's scratching
again
um
that's their problem
you know i don't know jason lawhead
knows the game better than me he also
says that coach stinks and larry bird
should literally walk down and fire the
guy
during the game and just take over
because he's getting brutally out
coached i have no idea i'm just actually
happy that i'm
watching the nba again again i just wish
these [ __ ] refs would just put their
[ __ ] whistles away
or at least just be consistent i i they
they are the [ __ ] worst and i know in
every sport you can have bad officiating
and you can have [ __ ] calls but like the
nba is
is at the top of the [ __ ] list
because it goes beyond bad calls it go
because with their power they can put
guys on the bench it [ __ ] drives me
nuts
relax bill okay i will um let's talk
some hockey here
how about those [ __ ] rages
i have never
i can't i think the last time i was just
wrong about somebody
the the [ __ ] patriots traded blue
drew bledsoe to the buffalo bills and i
was like that guy's gonna come back to
harness and i forgot that the poor
bastard was playing for the [ __ ]
bills
and it isn't his fault but i thought
they were going to come back and kill us
um and i also thought that tom brady got
lucky his first year that's what i
thought see so i don't know [ __ ] and i
also just have not been believing in the
ranges and here they are one game away
ladies and gentlemen the new york
[ __ ] rangers who tortured their fans
every [ __ ] year except 1994 since
1940 they've been torturing those
[ __ ] they are one game away
from going to the stanley cup finals
um
it's been a great see what a [ __ ]
game that was i mean it could easily be
2-2
um just an incredible game yesterday and
um
i really enjoyed uh
i've really been enjoying that series
because um i know the canadians aren't
gonna quit
i think they're gonna win the next one
and uh then it'll be game six it's gonna
[ __ ]
you know add pressure to the rangers
like [ __ ] we can't lose this one because
then we're gonna we we don't want a game
seven with these guys i'm basically
praying for both series both the kings
hawks
and the uh rangers um canadians to go
seven games same thing with the
basketball even though it doesn't look
like it's going to
um
i want more hockey more hoop
okay to bridge the gap between the end
of those series
and the beginning of nfl football but
then again why am i [ __ ] on the
national past time why don't i just
[ __ ] embrace that too
that's what i should do i don't [ __ ]
know but um
and then then the hawks king series has
just been [ __ ] ridiculous
um
the hawks came out game one it they just
looked like what everybody thought they
were
just this this i guess they if they win
it this year they are considered a
dynasty
one you know what's funny is the level
the amount of teams
and how hard it is to win a championship
has increased over the years that when i
was a kid you had to win three in a row
to be a dynasty and then three and four
years like they gave it to the patriots
where we won one buccaneers won and then
we won we won we won three in four years
and they said that was a dynasty
and now
hockey chicago won
2010
2013
and then if they win again this year
they were going to give them a dynasty
um
whatever you want to call it it's
[ __ ] impressive what they're doing
because they lose guys every year but
they're somehow able to
to not um
dip in quality like the way we did
you know we made some moves got rid of
tyler sagan some of those guys got a
little bit older a little little more
inexperienced at the same time and i
think that hurt us in the end
um what the hawks are doing amazing but
then the [ __ ] kings come roaring back
was it six to two just kicked their ass
and then
the hawks come back game three i think
and it was just that was just like a
heavyweight battle
them just going at it and uh i can't
can't wait if you listen to this podcast
before game tonight jump on the [ __ ]
bandwagon if you just want to watch
hockey at its highest level watch the
king's hawk series it's [ __ ] insane
um
i actually tried to get tickets for
tonight didn't work out i don't think
it's gonna work out
i called up my connection and it ain't
[ __ ] happening there but uh i'm
definitely gonna be
watching that series dry
do you guys know i'm one day away from
40 days without a drop of booze
[ __ ] brutal
you know
i swear to god if i went to an a.a
meeting right now and they tried to give
me one of those chips i'd throw it out
of
you know
[ __ ] throw it at him just start
screaming i'm not enjoying this
um
i like that i've lost some weight but
i'm getting ready to do a special
everybody and tickets are on sale
if you want to be at the live taping of
my next special so you can say to your
loved ones i was there when that hour of
filth was recorded
um i will have the link up tickets are
going fast thank god i'm going to be at
the
tabernacle in um
atlanta georgia and i can't wait to come
back it's one of my favorite theaters
and uh
i'm really hoping um
i don't know i'm nervous about this one
man i gotta try to top my last one
which is the only thing you can really
do is just try to top your last one and
um
i don't know yeah i gotta get myself in
the mindset i'm not in the mindset yet
that mindset has to be where you don't
give a [ __ ] but you do
and you're having fun and you're
improving
like i would during a normal show so i
basically have to block out
that's the thing you block out that the
cameras are there and then you also
don't start thinking like oh [ __ ] i
missed a tag who gives a [ __ ] nobody's
gonna know
okay you're not documenting the joke
you're documenting like that night's
performance of the joke and that's the
way it came out once you do that
then you can [ __ ] free yourself up so
um
whatever i just want to [ __ ] do it
already i was supposed to be doing it
the first week
and i was going to do it in san
francisco but uh
the [ __ ] unions up there jesus christ
[ __ ] be i'm pro unit beating the [ __ ]
out of me
you gotta [ __ ] hire 15 guys to uh
bring the mic stand out on the [ __ ]
stage and i'm like oh [ __ ] this place
let me go across the street yeah it's
going to be 16 guys
all right you know what
all the leaves are brown
[ __ ] this town
i went to atlanta i'm definitely coming
back now i'm just going to do i'm just
going to do san francisco i'm just not
going to [ __ ] film there
it's unreal you know bad i i wanted to
i wanted to
but those wacky unions
um anyways
what else am i talking about here um
jesus christ did i did i do all my
topics already am i already into the
questions well i am 30 minutes in
um i'm actually supposed to be going to
a uh to a barbecue
um
i had the guy actually all my buddies
over on uh
on saturday and we watched game three
the kings game dude was [ __ ] great
and um
you know grilled up some steaks i'm one
of those guys too i don't give a [ __ ]
i'll let somebody somebody's like man
let me grill those up go ahead and grill
them up i don't give a [ __ ]
you know i was upstairs making the
[ __ ] garlic mashed potatoes like a
[ __ ] lady i don't care
i really don't give a [ __ ] i know that
really [ __ ] with my man card that i
have another guy come over here and jump
on my grill i don't give a [ __ ]
i really don't i just want to make sure
people have drinks
you know i'm up here wearing my apron
i'm really in touch with my feminine
side when i turn on my grill
law heads cooked on it now court mccown
[ __ ] made the stakes on it
you know it's not like i don't cook on
it but i just i don't know
the steaks look so good i actually got
some anxiety is like i don't want to
[ __ ] these up court threw him on he
handled them and i i was up here and i
made potatoes
[Music]
ah what a [ __ ]
ah jesus christ
oh my god i hope my dad doesn't listen
to this um
i got a couple other frozen ones up
there
i'll throw them on
they'll make them for me my wife
uh what a [ __ ] anyways
uh
sorry that's just making me [ __ ]
laugh
i really am dude i'm either a [ __ ]
type a
alpha male or i'm wearing an apron i
really am a gemini it all depends on the
situation i will either not take an
ounce of [ __ ] or i will let you roll
right the [ __ ] over me as i hand you my
wallet it all depends on the situation
um yeah bill it's called being a
schizophrenic go [ __ ] yourself um all
right
all right the big thing in my life is uh
yesterday
i went out and i bought a new snare drum
and i can't wait because i bought this
old ludwig kit
and i know i've been threatening a long
time to be doing these drum covers but
i'm getting close i got my drum kit and
uh
about an early 70s green sparkle all
[ __ ] bottom sizes so now i'm like and
of course they never come with the snare
i don't know what happens with the snare
people just want to keep the [ __ ]
snare
they break up the kids so i went out
you know i was looking on the internet
trying to find a [ __ ] 1971 ludwig six
and a half by 14 [ __ ] snare and i
just can't find i was just like you know
what why don't you just go buy a new one
and then you know if one comes along and
you whatever you add it to the [ __ ]
kid who gives a [ __ ] but uh
i bought it and now does it sound sweet
it sounds sweet and i've been practicing
a lot i've been on the practice pad big
time and what i'd learned yesterday when
i got behind a kit is the practice pad
is not a drum kit and i sounded like
[ __ ]
and then what was funny was
i went over to go buy a snare drum
afterwards
and when they were trying to see if they
had a hard shell case for it i was uh i
got down i sat on one of those the v
drums the electronic kits
and um
those things sound so unbelievable like
i was joking with the buddy now dean del
rey
from the uh
let there be talk podcast in the all
things comedy network
you know we went over there together and
uh
i was joking with the most with those
electronic drums like you sit behind a
real kit you're like oh my god i suck
thank god nobody's here to listen to
this you get behind the electronic kits
and you're just like how come i'm not in
a band i'm [ __ ] awesome like they
sound so unbelievable
and they're so forgiving
um i sat down on those uh those v drums
i'll tell you right now if you ever
wanted to play drums and you're worried
about how loud they're going to be and
you just want to have fun
you got to get get the [ __ ] v drums
and this is not a commercial just get
this is just me saying this just get the
[ __ ] v drums because you can actually
control the volume of them
you can play them with headphones you
can be downstairs your wife can't even
hear it whatever your roommates or
whatever if you live in an apartment all
you do is you go out and you get um
you know those little i think i've
talked about this before you know those
things
those overly protective parents get in
the playroom those interlocking like
little rubber
uh spongy floor things so if your kid
falls down he doesn't hurt himself
you just get those
and you get two layers of it and you put
it underneath the kit and then you go
downstairs to your downstairs neighbor
you say hey my name's so and so this is
my phone number
all right
if i'm ever playing any and you're at
home
call me up and i will stop immediately
if anybody has a problem with that
they're a [ __ ]
and then you should play at two in the
morning all right there you go so that's
what's going on in my life let me read
the last of the advertising here and
we'll get into your questions there oh
by the way the all things comedy um
once a month we do a show we do a
stand-up show
and uh
the little money that we make goes to
help paying the rent at our studio
we do it at the bootleg theater tomorrow
night listen to this [ __ ] lineup all
right
we got we got dave kechner
david keckner
from uh
anchorman we got dana gould
dana gould one of the greatest stand-up
comics ever
this we got we got al madrigal
and we got the we got the muscle
from the rose bowl tailgate legend
joe bartnick that's just for we got tom
papa
tom pop it's a it's a it's a killer line
there's not a better [ __ ] show
in los angeles tomorrow night you got to
go out you got to go check it out help
support the all things comedy network
um
i i i would appreciate it as with
everybody else
over here at all things comedy all right
hulu plus everybody
hulu plus
you've probably tried hulu on your
computer hulu plus is so much more with
hulu plus you can watch current season
episodes of your favorite shows like
modern family the daily show and scandal
and watch every episode of shows like
nashville my wife loves that show lost
and doctor who you get
ad-free movies and kids show two kid
shows too sorry now more than ever there
is so much to watch take total control
with hulu plus to stream these shows and
thousands more as much as you want
wherever you want hulu plus works on
your computer smartphone smart tv roku
apple tv xbox playstation pretty much
any streaming device you already own you
can even watch on your eye on your phone
or your ipad while on the train at work
at the dentist or in the bathroom you
can even block off a data ben to binge
dude i got to start doing this man
because the way i'm on the road this is
[ __ ] great
it's [ __ ] great man i love it you'll
also get access to originals
all two originals that you can get
anywhere else check out
the new show deadbeat a comedy about a
pot smoking guy who talks to ghost binge
on all 10 episodes starting april 9.
uh for only 7.99 a month you get your
shows anytime anywhere that's like a
quarter a day come on people right now
sign up at huluplus.com bill or click on
the banner on my website and get two
weeks full access completely free that's
a whole extra week more with this
special offer when you sign up at
huluplus.com bill so get with it and
start streaming tv now with hulu plus
and last mercifully the last reader this
week sorry guys
i'm extra bad this week uh legalzoom
everyone
america was built by innovators and
dreamers
jesus that's a rosy picture
innovators dreamers and
homicidal maniacs uh people like thomas
edison oh what a swell guy he was and
henry ford oh yeah that anti-semite laid
the foundations for our country i don't
know if he would i don't know if i'm
confusing henry ford walt disney uh
these days it's the you know what that's
not even their fault it's just because
of when they were born that was
acceptable
um these days it's the inventors and the
entrepreneurs all around us like you
that keep our country running by fueling
the job market and the economy this
month legalzoom celebrates innovation by
helping you launch your dream apply for
a patent to secure your invention
exactly this is exactly if you're out
there inventing stuff you need legalzoom
to to get a patent before those
corporate you know what's steal it from
you alright and if they want to buy your
idea don't ever give them ownership of
it ever you never give up ownership all
right
i was kidding if you don't give them
part ownership they'll just steal it
from you and be like what go ahead and
sue us
i'm telling people we need to march up
that solar road sorry apply for a patent
to secure your invention register your
trademark to protect your products and
services incorporate or form an llc and
launch your business this is how you do
it people this is how you protect
yourself visit legalzoom.com and use the
discount code burr they'll provide the
personal attention you need and help
take care of all the details they've
helped over one million businesses get
started
and get started right and they received
an a plus from the better business
bureau these are the guys everybody
celebrate innovation with legalzoom
today and get a special price on
trademark copyright or provisional
patent applications by using the
discount code bur burr checkout once
again legalzoom provides legal help
through independent attorneys and
self-help but they are not a law firm
legalzoom.com discount code burr that's
the way you set it up everybody if you
got a great idea you have to protect
yourself
from day one because they will try and
steal it from you all right every
business is the same my business is no
different all right you write the show
you bring it to them we love it we own
it and then we're going to pay you this
and then during residuals that gets cut
in half and it gets cut in half again
and then one day we're sending you
checks for six cents and we're still
collecting millions and then if you
audit us we're going to label you as
difficult
that's how it works everybody
so go to legalzoom all right
okay here we go um
what's what does this say good meal good
emails also mentioned the monday morning
podcast oh yeah the monday morning
podcast we have our own twitter account
finally if you'd like to follow the mm
podcast and get the links for all the
videos and all the stuff that i talk
about follow us here at the mm podcast
um our twitter handle is at the mmp uh
podcast
at the mm podcast and mmp is all
capitalized
all right okay
here we go uh first one bruins bill why
didn't the bruins just take out carrie
price ranger figured this out in game
one
um ah come on man you don't want to do
that [ __ ] you don't deliberately hurt
somebody
um but i will say that i i don't think
carrie price
is quite as good as people say is if you
go up top you got the guy unless you
miss it every [ __ ] time the way we
did
we really uh
we really screwed the [ __ ] pooch but
um i definitely think he's one of the
elite goalies in the league but i
wouldn't i think
i'd say the kings might quick is the
best
is it my quicker am i is that the
[ __ ] guy from the eagles
i'm so [ __ ] old i just combined
generations of people
i gotta look this up now
jonathan quick mike quick yeah my quick
play for the eagles i knew that didn't
sound right i've watched people i've
watched all three [ __ ] games
and they've said jonathan quick a
zillion times and i still sit right
quick my [ __ ] brain stopped retaining
information somewhere around the earl uh
late 80s early 90s
my apologies to jonathan quick i think
he's the best
i'll tell you who i don't think is as
[ __ ] good as his num his numbers
is uh the blackhawks crawford
i just think he has an incredible group
of people in front of him
and uh he plays with the lead a lot so
people can get back on deep but i've
noticed you know
all of a sudden they start chasing a
little bit they got to take their
chances
i'll tell you that five holes looking
pretty tasty there um sorry
anyways whatever uh
i got to be honest with you if we took
out carrie price i mean i don't think it
would have made a difference the
canadians they were just better than us
and they're moving in the right
direction and i hope that we do so uh
there you go all right
all right dilemma
the dilemma here for the week bill i
haven't heard you read a dilemma in a
while
here's one would you rather fight three
rabbit dogs
with the thirst for blood with a sword
oh yeah i could [ __ ] take him out
or take your chances with one bullet and
a bear
coming at you from a hundred yards away
keep in mind the dogs can kill you and
that it can take more than one bullet to
kill a bear absolute [ __ ] lutely i
know that hey i don't know that i've
just watched enough youtube videos
um
i actually saw youtube videos running
watching one of those fail win videos
and why do they always have to put a
picture of some hot chick bending over
and then she's never in it
it's like i'm going to watch it anyways
what are you getting my hopes up for
watching people fail and and succeed
is compelling it's compelling enough you
don't have to put some chip with the
[ __ ]
you know
bikini covered clam [ __ ] winking at
me in the beginning of it and then it's
not there it's false advertising you
[ __ ] you know what i'm doing is i'm
starting to just click on the ones that
don't have that
[ __ ] [ __ ] stand on the merit of
the footage you stole
but anyways i was watching one of those
fail win videos
and uh
there was this guy he was hunting wild
boar
and he [ __ ] shoots at the thing he
misses and the [ __ ] thing turns
around and just starts running at him he
misses again and then he [ __ ] ran
away
dude you just got your best what are you
gonna outrun a [ __ ] wild boar you're
nuts
unless your trucks right there
i'm telling you you gotta just stand
there
if i had to shoot a [ __ ] bear
in the head
you got to shoot him in the [ __ ] head
you gotta wait to the absolute last
second i'm talking about urinating down
both sides of your pant leg just stand
there like ah
and just waiting
so you can almost feel his breath and
you better have a [ __ ] 50 caliber and
you just fire that [ __ ]
um
yards away [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that oh my god and you know you can
feel the earth shaking as that thing's
coming at you i mean i'm just telling
you you're
that's just com all organs fail at that
point
uh
[ __ ] that
us uh rabid dogs [ __ ] yeah absolutely
with the sword the great thing about a
sword
is that gives me a little bit of
distance
all right
how do i meet these rabid dogs
am i lowered into a pit as they see me
are they running at me
if all three are running at me i stand
there and right as they the first one
starts to leap
i do a little sidestep a little sashay
if you will and i [ __ ] just come
right down
um whatever whatever meat i can hit
and if that what i'm gonna do is i'm
actually gonna alligator arm it because
the last thing i want to have happen is
for that sword to get stuck in that
thing's flesh as the other two take take
it over i'm really getting into this
i'd [ __ ] give him a nice [ __ ]
right there fred right little chop to
him
send him to this side
then the other [ __ ] even if one of
them's biting me my move is i'm hacking
your leg
i'm hacking your [ __ ] duck and the
people right now are like oh my god i
love dogs shut up it's hypothetical and
they're rabid they got to be put down
anyways and they're trying to kill me
oh billy redface who who [ __ ] side you
want here
so that that would be my big move
that would be my my big move like i've
always thought if i
was ever hiking and somebody i i came
upon somebody getting mauled
by a a mountain lion
if ever i was actually i mean i mean i
know what i would do in real life i'd be
like well sucks for him
didn't see that sorry what am i supposed
to do get mauled too so i can get on the
news [ __ ] that um
but if for some reason it was somebody i
gave a [ __ ] about and they were gonna
die
i would
i would run like a native american
really [ __ ] softly and i would leap
in the air
and i would [ __ ] matt cook
that mountain lion one of his back legs
i would just [ __ ] land on its leg and
try to blow out
you know and it's
end its lateral [ __ ] movement and it
will just [ __ ]
you know
the great thing about wild animals the
great thing about animals
in general is they don't have a [ __ ]
ego
okay so they just kind of like you know
when something like that happens they're
just like okay i need to go lay down and
heal even though that's not going to
[ __ ] heal that that's i don't know so
whatever that's that's how i would take
the three dogs
i i would give a nice jab with the sword
to the first one that came to me i'd
take the bite of the second one i'd hack
the leg of the third one and then i'd
[ __ ] start finishing them off that's
what i would do and then i would go to
the hospital uh
with all three carcasses
and i would say i got bit by two out of
three of these they're all [ __ ] rabid
and uh go ahead stick those needles in
my stomach
let's get it over with and chain me to
the radiator let's see if i go mad or
something you know
[ __ ]
all right
i like the dilemmas let's bring the
dilemmas back i also liked youtube
videos of the week there was a lot of
there was a lot of [ __ ] things out
there
ah remember back then we used to have
topics all right corporate bullies
dear bill i used to be a bully not a
terrible one but the harmless eddie
haskell type um
all right see more just you just like a
just an [ __ ] all right harmless as i
may have been i'm sure i heard some
feelings it made some experiences less
fun for those at the other end my
question to you is how can i make this
right
i know i can't trace down the kids i
grew up with
but i see people being dicks in
corporate america and want to call them
out without losing my job do i tease
them in the same style we did as
children or take a serious route and
give a denzel speech
all right first of all why can't you try
track down the kids you grew up with
it happens all the time on facebook i
bet you can find a lot of them you can
go to a high school reunion
um
you could do it that way
i think that would be a great thing to
make you feel better and say hey i'm an
adult now i shouldn't have done that
sorry that i uh
i dumped your books and gave you a
[ __ ] wedgie whatever the [ __ ] you did
um
i don't know how that works in
corporate america
i wouldn't give a denzel speech
that those speeches only work in the
movies
um do i tease them in the same style we
did as children well you know you need
to elaborate
they're bullying people
um
i don't know you know in the job place
if somebody's getting bullied that's
really just on them
you know and just the amount of [ __ ]
that they've decided that they want to
take in life
you know
it'd be one thing you know if someone
was like you know putting his secretary
in a headlock and was giving her noogies
you know what i mean
there was a bunch of [ __ ]
former athletes beating on some form of
athlete
you know
hanging outside his cubicle waiting for
him to go over to the water bubbler
they push him in a broom closet and
[ __ ] rough them up yeah then you got
to do something but if it's just like
mental torture
um
what i would do is i would walk up to
the person getting bullied when you get
a chance and just say listen man you got
to stick up for yourself stop taking
that [ __ ]
what's the guy gonna do
throw his cufflinks at you what are you
afraid of [ __ ] him
um
but i know in the work environment you
can't say hey [ __ ] you
you have to come
more you have to sit down to say can i
talk to you for a second
and then they'll listen to you and then
you gotta be like yeah listen i just
noticed you've been uh
you know coming at me in a manner that
that sort of indicates to me that you're
not pleased with something about me and
i was just wondering what that was
you know and just leave it at that see
what that is and then you know if they
want to sit there and try and make your
life miserable at that point
um
because i know there's all that passive
aggressive horseshit that goes on in an
office
um but i have not
fortunately never worked in that
arena tell you what you know what i need
a little help on this one everybody
um can you guys write in some not really
corporate bullies things can you write
in uh
some passive aggressive [ __ ]
that's been happening like they do they
want you to quit so they keep doing
stuff to you guys got any stories out
there i think those are interesting i
think those would help me fill up a
[ __ ] hour here on the block that um
all right
so yeah i i i would go to a high school
union
i'd go to a high school union i think
it'd be weird to reach out to somebody
on facebook hey sorry for being a dick
go to a high school reunion say it to
their face you know i would do that i
wouldn't reach out on facebook facebook
is just [ __ ] weird
um
anyways all right kid kid movies
uh
dear billy the kidless
oh just when you think there's not an
original one left that's a [ __ ] great
one he said i'm a father of two little
girls congratulations congratulations
all my free time is spent with them and
there's a lot of kids programming's
happening in my life i was wondering
the other day does bill like any kids
movies classics like the goonies or
disney animation don't worry even if you
don't like any now you will enjoy them
when your own child is getting all
giggly and bubbly over the sight of a
little mermaid
um of course i do i mean i didn't the
goonies i was too old when that came out
i was already a teenager so i was
watching more quality cinema like
youngblood
and uh roadhouse um
let me see here what do i oh yeah i like
all the disney stuff
um
i never liked mickey mouse's voice
though i liked goofy i liked pluto
donald duck was [ __ ] hilarious why
did they always make the duck be the
dick
you know did warner brothers rip off
donald duck with daffy duck
i hate and i hated daffy duck by the way
i couldn't stand that [ __ ] dude
and after a while i didn't like bugs
bunny either bugs bunny always won so he
was [ __ ] annoying and daffy duck was
just kind of this piece of [ __ ]
you know
he just you know he just would do [ __ ]
to [ __ ] himself over
you're not flying south for the winner
and now i'm supposed to feel bad for you
you
cleo i gotta give you another bath
what's wrong with you do you need a flea
treatment there cleodio
huh
you know what's funny about her when
she's anticipating me
either saying
if she wants to
well she's already i can't even say want
go to a play
basically outside
or
go for a ride
her ears
she's staring at me right now perk up
she looks like bat ears her eyes like
her eye she just locks in on me this
psycho pitbull look her ears come up and
she just stares at me with all senses
like did he just say what i said thought
he said
i would actually get her riled up but
it's a mean thing to do
you want me to do it fine i'll do it you
want to hear her howl
she does this every once in a while cleo
cleo do you want to go for a ride
huh
cleo
cleo
do
you
all right we'll go in a second
we'll go in a second go lay down go lay
down sorry
got you all excited you know what i just
did i just did like those fail wind
videos i put the hot chick in the
beginning didn't i i'm sorry buddy
good girl we'll go in a minute
um
okay um yeah i like um
i didn't like the little mermaid
i'm not into fish women it's just
[ __ ] weird and then there's always
some sort of like the guy ends up
[ __ ] the fish woman it's just it's
[ __ ] creepy like splash
you know
i mean this is really crude but you just
always think you know
you just think the downstairs is going
to be a little ripe if you know what i
mean
how do you tell do you look in her eye
her eyes cloudy you don't go down there
oh jesus that's a fish joke everybody
now that's how you pick out fresh fish
hey you know what
i actually looked up this recipe
this is my favorite thing on youtube
it's for garlic garlic mashed potatoes
and this is how the guy the way the guy
ends this video is so [ __ ] priceless
um
let me see if i can bring this up this
is this is the youtube video of the week
ah jesus with the advertising don't they
know everybody hits [ __ ] mute and
then scrolls down and you just look at
the yellow bar that's what i do
eight more seconds
six more seconds
three two
one
all right so basically uh
this guy makes potatoes are a delicious
side dish that paired well with meats
poultry
i just want you to hear this glad you
did
whoa whoa whoa whoa shut up shut up shut
up all right here we go so
he basically
i just said shut up to a video that's
how dumb i am
um he basically uh
makes these garlic mashed potatoes you
know in the end then they gotta try it
and tell you how [ __ ] delicious it is
this is it right here listen to what
this guy says this is this [ __ ]
this made my week here we go recipe
you'll be glad you did
thanks for tubing in
man that's good
[Music]
man that's good
yeah it's just that such [ __ ] guy you
could not get mad at that guy
i played that for nia right before we
went to bed last night and she she
almost fell out of the bed laughing he
goes thanks for youtubing
he goes that's garlic mashed potatoes
thanks for youtube and see you next time
and then he puts the garlic mashed
potatoes in his mouth and then he just
goes
man that's good
ah you know what in his videos we'll get
better because i've actually seen
outtakes where he's actually more
relaxed more like who he is he's just
been doing him
i don't know what's this from a few
years ago
yeah whatever i always believe that
people are going to get better all right
so here we go we got one more read here
all right first time
dear billy go lucky
i'm going to lose my v card next weekend
jesus christ
i always that always surprises me when
people know when they're going to lose
their virginity doesn't it just happen
like it did for me
you know like that's never going to
happen and then somebody just grabs your
dick and you're like oh [ __ ] here we go
then you're driving home yeah
i didn't know people planned it
right i think i just said somebody just
grabs your dick like it could be anybody
like some [ __ ] 60 year old man
gross
um
what was i gonna say like you guys
actually planned this [ __ ] out
it's going down next sunday um i'm gonna
lose my v card next weekend me and the
girl are corny high school lovebirds and
it couldn't be more right i think i know
the answer to this question but i'll ask
you anyways
should i blow it in her face
oh no
should i blow it in her face to
commemorate the occasion then he says
kidding real question
should i think about mixing up positions
or just keep it ida i love making
um yeah i
i gotta be honest with you i i never i
never hooked up with the virgin okay
the woman
it was a woman she was a woman that and
and she had been around the block
all right
so
there was no uh
yeah i don't know
i didn't have that experience i would
probably say the first time you do it
you don't want to flip her over
um
yeah
this is a big responsibility
i would try to keep it as
loving and as nice as you can
and uh
i would probably do that
the first half dozen to dozen times and
then you know
you know let it get comfortable there
buddy before you start [ __ ] trying to
you know what it is about your kids is
the amount of porn you've probably
watched
the access that you have to it you know
i wonder if if kids that's a [ __ ]
creepy thought sorry
strike that i wonder if i shouldn't even
say kids teenagers of age
i mean they got to be better at it than
we were
we had no idea all you had was rumors
when i was a kid you didn't know what
the [ __ ] you were doing
you had to figure it just you just
walked into the bush
no [ __ ] trail no nothing you guys are
why you guys are walking right down the
open highway
just do you know something i i didn't
even
the thought
of blowing it
in some woman's face like i i didn't
even
you didn't even think who even thought
of [ __ ] like that
i'm trying to think when the facial came
arriving when i was in high school like
the two pornos i think i ever saw
the big thing was when the vcr came out
and then all of a sudden you know and
then it was somebody had to have the
balls to go into through those [ __ ]
saloon doors at the back of the video
shop
and you just [ __ ] went in there you
just grabbed one really quick what'd you
get i don't know
it had tits and then you [ __ ] went
out like
nobody did that
right nobody [ __ ] i'm trying to think
the first time i even saw that first
time i saw it i thought it was [ __ ]
gross like a lot of porn you're like oh
my god that's disgusting and then you're
like oh my god that's the only thing
that gets me off then you move to the
next level which is the danger of porn
right you just keep going further and
further down the [ __ ] abyss and next
thing you know you could work on a vice
squad without getting sick while you're
eating a [ __ ] mayonnaise sandwich
over there sorry this is getting gross
but it's true
and if elected
no child under the age of 18 will be
allowed to watch somebody bust it in
somebody's face
ask not
whose face you can bust it in um
yeah wow jesus i mean even like your
question like how [ __ ] uh
advanced you already are if you never
[ __ ] did anything
because when i like i said there was no
video we had no game film
when i was a kid that you guys could sit
there and go over and over and over like
[ __ ] bill belichick we had no there
was no game film and then because there
was so little information you had to act
like you knew everything and someone
would bring something up
and
you you and you'd be sitting there on
the outside just total [ __ ] world
series of poker face and on the inside
you were panicking going what the [ __ ]
are they talking about what is that i
don't know what that is
you know
and i don't know if my dad knows what it
is but i'm certainly not talking about
it
up to him because that's [ __ ] gross
just talking to him about it would be
[ __ ] gross and then a whole other
level is he doing that to my mom how the
[ __ ] does he know that right
so
i don't know so like i said just keep it
i i love making i would leave it at that
all right and with that everybody that
is the monday morning podcast here for
memorial day
all right thank you to all the troops
anybody who's ever served
and uh
for giving me the wonderful life that i
have protecting my life and on and it
means a lot more to me now that i
actually you know got that chance to go
over there to omaha beach and everything
added a whole nother level of reality to
it
so uh that is it so thank you to all the
troops the rest of you guys go [ __ ]
yourselves i'll talk to you next week
um get your solar panels get your idea
patented and if you're making love to a
virgin this week let's try to keep it
eye to eye guys all right see
you